the Joe Rogan experience you know it's
like why I get annoyed at the Christian
Right you know their low is like
abortions or you're killing babies what
we need to do is have those babies and
support young mothers who support young
single moms I'm like when's the last
time you [ __ ] volunteer to support a
young single mom who had a baby
Christian dude posting on Twitter was
the last time you give a a Saturday of
your day to take that kid to the zoo
[ __ ] you say it but they don't
[ __ ] do when you think about it you
know it's a nice little box to put
yourself in for some people they think
they're a good person because they're a
Christian how much how much do you
really act but you're taking your day to
stand outside Planned Parenthood was a
sign why not take the day to go help
that kid who didn't get aborted and his
mom can't feed him
I don't go why not stop by there instead
of holding a sign about the devil yeah
if I could clinic for women it's just
weird it is weird
yes it's it's a weird thing that you can
do it too right I mean that's one of the
weird things about people is that we
know that if we don't do anything and we
take care of ourselves a baby's coming
and like if you get the first countdown
like countdown like it's almost like we
agree that there's like levels to the
countdown like in the first couple of
days no one gives a [ __ ] just pull the
plug pulled apart yeah and then
everyone's looking in everybody like you
feel okay everything what happened what
happened yeah it's not that big of a
deal it's like would we how many cells
was it it was only four cells at the
time okay four cells it's not a lot of
cells and you start thinking I don't
think it really ever can be four cells
what you get my play a tiny little thing
mm-hmm and then when does it become
Wendy's side to side that's a person I
get I get by the way it looks like one I
don't listen I get the argument and you
know I I do think that I have my own
personal philosophy on how I would
handle a situation but I don't if you
were a woman no no I'm saying if I was
in a relationship with a woman and she
got pregnant you're gonna have the kid
or did want to have a kid and I did you
know at the end of the day we'd have a
conversation together and if she was
dead set on doing it then we're gonna do
it you know because that but my point
being I do believe that like it's a
weird thing to just tell other people
what they're supposed to do or not I do
I feel that way about gay marriage I
feel that way about everything it's like
it's it's a strain
thing to be able to dictate to someone
else how they're supposed to live agree
because there's too many people doing
that man like we got them right doing it
through the Christian right then we got
the left doing it through you know all
their all their movements and it's like
I think the reason most people are
someone know it in the country isn't
like even political it's like they're
just sick of people telling them how to
live you know it's like I get it I can't
say that oh you want me to not have a
gun you hate guns yeah it's like it's
like everyone just [ __ ] stuff or it's
like we do you like a just like a
national timeout for five minutes think
we're just learning how to use this
thing man we're learning how to
integrate society into this kind of
communication that we share right now
just while you're still figuring it out
I did I talked about that with somebody
the other day I was actually just doing
a set on stage and I was ripping a
little bit about how you know we talked
about the Second Amendment a lot and the
founding fathers didn't know we were
gonna have assault rifles they didn't
have the foresight to see that so then
we have to rethink what that means and
it's like well they didn't know we were
gonna have Twitter right so like maybe
we have to rethink what the First
Amendment it's didn't know every [ __ ]
[ __ ] was gonna have the ability to say
stuff out like just at a national level
the Internet I mean imagine how easy it
was to govern people before the internet
came around yeah what's been so much
easy it just lie to them yeah lie to
them to have almost no access to the
truth yeah we get what Walter Cronkite
tells you [ __ ] yes all you get you get
it's like it's like it's like the
entertainment industry used to be like
you want to hear a song Merv Griffin and
Dick Clark will let you know what song
is you can hear you know you were on the
side of the people that are
anti-abortion there's one side of you
that has to logically interpret that if
these people really did feel like babies
were being murdered like it was their
perspective that babies were being
murdered if you completely ignore that
perspective and just try to say it's a
woman's health issue yeah like I get I
almost get where their mind is at I
don't think that they should be
interfering in anybody's life especially
when something is legal and yeah and
they and they fundamentally believe
that's what's happening and you could
see how yeah don't you hear thought
babies were being killed up the street
right we can't allow this to happen
or what I'm saying it'll tell you that
they are babies yeah and the problem
with that argument is it's it holds some
water sure like you really have to mean
is if you're gonna be a rational person
and I'm 100 percent
pro-choice but as a rational person you
have to look at what it actually is if
you don't then we're playing game the
game is you want your side to be correct
but the reality is this is a very
complicated weird thing yeah there's
like a life in your body and for sure
guys shouldn't be able to tell a girl
what you can do totally agree with them
can't you can't tell a woman she has to
keep it people have already aborted
babies there's a precedent for you can't
tell them one thing could do all you can
do is support their decision or can
weigh in I think if we were their dad
you can weigh in on what you want but at
the end of the day it's she's gonna
decide what she wants to do and you just
got to agree with it yeah and that's the
move I think you know it's just it's a
very complicated thing they like a life
form that will eventually become a
person is inside your body what do you
do like you imagine we had to make that
decision yeah we're lucky that chicks do
it because we don't think correctly for
that for that proposition no ability to
do way those ashes but I do think that
the that you know the when I think about
that I agree with you and I and I think
most issues in the country are like that
and that's the whole problem there's no
rationality in either side
[Applause]